- It's time I shared
something extraordinary
from social media.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
In 2018, while surfing in Hawaii
Doug lost his beloved custom
surfboard in a massive wave.
Then, get this, it was
found two years later,
5,000 miles away.
The board ended up in the
hands of a local school teacher
in the Philippines,
who amazingly was able to track Doug down.
Now the two men have formed a bond
and are working together
for a great cause.
Let's get Doug on the line, everybody.
What's up Doug.
- Hi, Kelly.
- What's up, man.
So, tell us about the surfboard
and how you managed to find it?
- So the surfboard
happened to be shaped by an amazing surfer
and it wasn't cheap.
I'd saved up money to buy it.
It was the most expensive
thing I owned at the time.
I finally surfed on it enough
where I came to end up losing it.
And that was devastating to me.
It really bummed me out.
Lo and behold, I'm waking up one morning
and I find a picture posted on Instagram
with my name tagged on it.
And it happened to be a
picture of that surfboard.
- Wow!
I mean, first of all I gotta tell you,
carrying that damn thing looks hard
let alone surfing with it.
I'm like, how do you carry it?
And now your close friends, right?
- Yeah.
So, Javan, the teacher who has my board,
we've been talking a lot
and after time went by
I said, "Hey, you know what?
You bought this board to surf it
and you wanna learn how to surf."
So I just thought I'd
send him surf supplies.
Well, his first reaction
was, "Don't do that.
Can you send me magazines
so my students can learn to read English?"
So I said, "Well, I think I
could do better than that."
Since this story is
getting so much exposure
I thought I'd do a GoFundMe.
And from then until now,
I've raised about $7,000 for his students.
(audience applauding)
- Wow! Isn't that crazy?
That must be the best
purchase of your life,
that to really transform everything.
- Yeah.
That's the best feeling to be able to help
people who I think might be
more unfortunate than we are.
- I know, but just to purchase.
I was talking about the surfboard.
You've purchased that surfboard,
you put all that money
you saved, you lose it
and then it ends up being
like the best money ever spent
in such a different way.
- Yeah.
So, the best $1,500 I ever lost.
(laughing)
- Well, thank you so much, Doug.
And thank you for all that you're doing.
It's a really beautiful thing
what you're doing right now
for his students.
Thank you so much. I'm liking
your post right now, right?
- Thank you. Thank you for having me.
- Absolutely. Well, that's not all.
This season we've actually
partnered with Pilot G2 Pen,
the go-to pen at the Kelly Clarkson show
and they wanna recognize great
people doing great things.
So they're gonna give you $1000.
- Oh, no way. That's amazing.
Awesome.
(laughing)
- Well, thank you so much, Doug.
Have a blessed day, all right?
- Thank you.